basically trying to disarm an audience
as much as you can with comedy and then
really punch him in the gut with a drama
as when they least expect it and I think
an audience makes himself so vulnerable
and open to you when when they're
laughing when they allow you to make
them laugh that's
um that's when they trust you foolishly
we would produce new writing nights in
London on a monthly basis and they would
all be about how to elicit a very
specific kind of response out of the
audience would be different each time
but you could tell like what things were
working what wasn't working when an
audience would fall in love and I hadn't
sort of realized but the two years of
producing those short shorts nights kind
of led to the whole play of blue bag a
friend of mine kind of asked me to do a
10 minute slot you know kind of
Storytelling sort of stand-up night
which is something I've never done
before but when she kind of bullied me
into doing it I just decided I was going
to use those 10 minutes just to play
around with practicing what I've been
preaching about that kind of character
so then I started writing her from
uh beyond that 10 minute show